there's that classic thing that a lot of
people do in talks we're like jump
everybody get up and now jump high and
then they say and now everybody jump
high and every [ __ ] person jumps
higher
hey brother how are you well good to see
you
coughing thank you son brother hurry my
hands getting tired how are you good to
see you man get me bud you're here
I'm trying ready
everything has a purpose it's really
funny I'm such a funny personality when
the cameras on that I think people think
like I'm just throwing [ __ ] at the wall
like right I'm very high energy yes but
it's actually I would think we can be
more than one spirit if you don't
understand I virtually don't do anything
without the calculated rationale behind
them right so so it's the way I think
about it is gateway drugs to the clothes
and a lot of times people try to put the
please unit but it's too heavy that's
cool all right exponent I'll see you
later see you later so you're really
getting thin man yeah yours melting I
might have a happen you know what I
think we're gonna do the askgaryvee show
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 217 in the ask gary vee
show
what's up periscope decide the I'm just
waiting for my next meeting
so trying to uh leverage every second
and create some content I have no idea
it's a long time is freaking me out I
don't even know what I'm doing
like there's just been a lot of cancel
don't sinner cool so last week I was on
call with James and Claud
there was a lot of HR and operations
stuff going on and kind of just you know
the tone and the vibe got me to really
you know thinking and over the weekend I
sent Claude an email and said do me a
favor I want you to put together a group
of individuals and here's the criteria
predicated on people's uh time spent a
veiner or what positions they hold I
think we're in a really interesting time
in vaynermedia's history and there was a
series of different things that have
happened over the last hundred days that
make me feel that there was a there's
not a disconnect but an opportunity for
me to do what I do as a CEO and that's
what this is about so Claude was making
a point about something and I said
Claude
there is no kool-aid there's no [ __ ]
kool-aid
enough of this kool-aid talk this is our
water this is what we do kool-aid is
what what negative people in this
company say to you guys if you're
positive because they're just keeping it
real
I can't single-handedly anymore you know
I probably never could to begin with but
no question
I can't single-handedly be responsible
for this culture alone I've got a sit
and I'm very affected I think by what's
happening in the outside world you know
London UK breaking from the EU probably
what's happening right now with the
political race what what has happened
you know in the same way that I realized
that people can use snapchat three years
ago it's the same thing that I'm
realizing consumer behavior it's just
easier to be cynical
the unhappy minority are dramatically
louder than the happy majority and we
have a major case of that at Vayner
we're living in a world where it's
easier to look at the negative and what
why you're here today
is you're part of the group that I need
help from I sense something the other
day I'm like [ __ ] man I might as well
actually run this business like
everybody else does because at least
I'll make the money because I'm pouring
money into trying to make the culture
great but if the collective culture like
if it's just so easy for everybody to
default into the negative the [ __ ] am I
doing here like oh wait a minute maybe
people have tried to do what I've done
before they just give up because you
become disappointed I'm hypersensitive
to one person crying in the bathroom I'm
hypersensitive to one person talking
[ __ ] for two days in a row at their
table like I just don't want anybody
upset so this is gonna become a binary
company in January like if I just start
all over I'm okay with that
I'm being dead serious I'm weird I'm
very weird either you fully believe in
what I and what this company is about or
you don't change is forever here there's
never gonna be a time we grow up there's
never gonna be a time where we slit like
it's for it as long as I am the CEO of
vaynermedia change is the only thing
that's not gonna change right it's just
who we are I can taste that we're six
months away from the moment that will
start the moment to be the downfall of
this company so I have no interest in
letting that happen so I'm just getting
massively ahead of it going on the
offense like I do no defense for me if I
smell it like I don't think we're there
but I think we can be there because what
are they gonna tell you like
that's the punchline everybody's gonna
always believe Rick over vaynermedia and
I want to reverse that happens
everywhere he doesn't care cuz running
their business I'm gonna answer you he's
running their business 427 percent
margin and they actually go the other
way they binary don't give a [ __ ] at all
so for me if I'm running a nine percent
margin and I'm giving up millions of
dollars I'd like to get the benefit of
that's what so that's what's happened
it's a bomb going into [ __ ] me well
then everybody has done the bucket and
said [ __ ] if I'm leaving 14 million
dollars in cash for myself on the table
to make a good place per year and I
can't do it if I'm a if I'm a [ __ ]
kool-aid guy to begin I might as well
take the [ __ ] money so let me let me
bounce around a little bit
football stories how much are you
willing to tell football stories as a
gateway drug to getting more people into
your funnel great so we're gonna you're
an app you're gonna create your public
stuff okay
and you'll navigate maybe outlook levers
got the bandwidth like maybe I'll think
you lead or what have you
all right I'll you guys can continue to
hang here and ask some more questions
before you wreck enough to guys well
I'll talk you soon all right
my friend hello how are you alright such
a pleasure good to see you
where we go where am I going my office
great come on in
happy belém I'm very I'm surrounded by
huge fans of yours that's very nice yeah
that say that you're building something
incredible here well thank you can you
tell me what you do yes I'm trying to
build the best marketing machine in the
world and some people are starting to
understand it by the way my man you and
I come from the same religion that by
the way this agency is the same thing
for the biggest brands in the world and
advertising that you're doing for music
we're the closest thing that any brand
could hire if they understand what's
actually happening look like this is a
20 year execution so I'm not I'm okay
with the shit-eating years but you're
absolutely right but I want you to know
one thing please know that I'm super
here for anything that doesn't make
sense
predicated on what you think the
religion is or what you think you're
buying into or what you think I'm about
or what you think the logo is about
never fester on things I'm I'm I'll
answer anything every day always I'm
okay yeah I'm always worried that people
think I'm Way too if this guy following
me around I'm traveling a look I'm here
anybody that's been here as long as you
I'm always most interested in what
they're interested in is there a put in
a position to succeed that that has me
excited because that could be the kind
of thing that we're gonna add to the
team on in October you know what I mean
that might have to make it I would say
that you always want to go as broad with
the title as you can yeah because when
you pigeonhole or you create things then
everybody raises their hand and says
that
I am trying to everybody's made it I
know exactly but yeah that's awesome
that's great hey sweet you know pleasure
yeah she's she's doing great and she's
great she can have Marge oh you can do
whatever that's the game hey really glad
you guys are all here hope everybody had
a great board I obviously this came
together pretty quickly I there's a
whole lot of things I want to talk about
and I and it's super important me and I
want you to hear just plain and simple
this will never be a company that cares
about short-term revenue and profit
margins yes these things matter but not
at the most macro level we want to be
the best version we can be we shouldn't
be silly we shouldn't be like you know I
don't want an eighth place trophy I want
to be the best and the nicest another
thing I'm gonna be spending a lot of
time talking about and it's gonna be a
big theme very shortly is change the
amount of change this company is going
to feel forever always is extreme and
will never change like we just can't
sweep under the rug
negativity Thanks bad stuff no more I am
unable to in the next year get a
shocking majority of this company to
believe what's in my heart and brain
then I'm gonna reset a very substantial
way somebody can I guys
I thought that was super duper
productive by far the best
it's not even close up right far away
yeah I'm realer people actually like put
their part of the solution instead what
they actually thought I think it's
winnable I understand that
you're trying to scale the unskilled
work trying to song reader human
behaviors but I you know I oftentimes
say it's a dictatorship and what I mean
about culture and I really think I can
pull it off and I think most important I
think but least make an effort in trying
to pull it off and the allocation of
time and effort moves the needle and
moves the ball further down the path and
any other good organization and I think
the second you believe that you can't
you can't push it as far there's that
classic thing that a lot of people do in
talks for like jump everybody get up and
now jump high and then they say and now
everybody jump high and every [ __ ]
person jumps high I'm not looking to
create a bunch of minimis I'm trying to
push them further down the path it's why
use the analogy of jumping up now jump
higher if I can just get everybody the
only thing I can pull off is pushing
everybody for the best versions of
themselves that this thing this is this
is pushing the envelope on the culture
front and and more importantly making
them realize what I'm really driven by
as long as they understand that
the why of it you know and I said it
like because I believe that it's a
better business it makes it like it's
suffocating a lot of this is so selfish
I'm suffocated in negativity I don't
know how you gonna pull it off by tenure
wall isn't it super intense
Cetacea are you gonna end of this one
very very very productive that's a good
day's work 16 hours of good days of work
doing the right thing is always the
right thing and I'm gonna always do that
you know the funny part is on that note
I expect to do things that are wrong in
the future that we will have to deal
with cynicism and I do have to really
build relationships up I'm surely not
willing to take it now when we have
you